doesn't have to be me or you but you
have to figure out whether this person's
there for dollars or whether they're an
honest broker and whether they tell you
the things you don't want to hear even
when it hurts what you know is the
anchor or the host's side right that's
how I would make my decision but on
something this complex you really do
need to be choosy about where you get
your info I mean most of these anchors
on CNN or MSNBC forget that are you know
a bunch of twits who have absolutely no
education on any of this stuff and are
too lazy to do their homework they they
want to be Stars Dave they don't want to
actually be your guide through something
as complex as the Israeli Palestinian
relationship they don't want to do a
deep dive on Hamas and Gaza and what
happened in 2005 and what happened you
know what who started bombing who first
and why and why the blockade was put
into they don't care they want what gets
them clicks and what gets you clicks
amongst the young people today is to say
that Israel is a
colonialized and that they're the
oppressor and that you're on the side of
the oppressed cuz that's what's hip
today you're a BLM and they're oppressed
and you're on the side of the lgbtq
people because they're the oppressors
they're not aggressors and therefore
you're on the side of the Palestinians
SL Hamas the poor Hamas oppressed people
who live in the new term quote an open a
prison I'm Dave Ruben this is the Reuben
report and you know what this woman just
does not need an introdu ction Megan
Kelly my friend and and actual I'm going
to consider you a journalist I'm not
sure that's what you consider yourself
anymore hello how are you my friend hi
I'm good how you doing Dave I'm all
right I'm all right I think it's
actually uh perfectly fitting to have
you on the show this week we were
supposed to do this a couple weeks ago
and then I think both our schedules went
a little wacky but to have you on uh
today obviously right in the middle of
this Israel Hamas thing uh and just sort
of really what I want to focus on I
guess and then we can you know me we can
talk about whatever you want to talk
about is sort of like the media reaction
to this and how we're seeing like a new
type of War unfold online and if it
wasn't for Twitter right now and you
know if it was the old days for you back
at your corporate job at Fox how maybe
you'd have to cover it differently or
even at NBC during that stint um so
maybe kind of take it from there like
well first off what do you make of the
last couple days just kind of broadly
and then we'll kind of try to narrow
it you know it reminds me of like 2015 I
think that's the right year when Isis
was getting really aggressive in the
Middle East and you'd go on the air at
night and ask yourself can I repeat any
of this can I show any of this video
this is so beyond the pale it's so evil
we're not going to show them burning
people alive in cages we're just not
going to do that and there were certain
lines that you wouldn't cross as a news
organization you know on cable and I'm
having that same feeling now like can
you show the the the absolute rape and
murder and torture of human beings in
Israel can you what should we and I've
been watching my friends in the media
make their own decisions in our digital
Lane which has different rules now you
know you you do have more freedom if you
make the editorial choice to show it and
we've been debating it internally it's
we can show it it's just there's only so
much the human heart can take MH you
know there's I don't know I'm sure you
because I know you've got
people you love there um but even I as
somebody who's got more distance between
me and and Israel and the actual events
but just as a supporter of Israel have
been walking around with just such a
heavy heart over the past few days it's
affecting everything it's affecting the
way I'm interacting with my family with
my friends you know my my sleeping
that's with all the distance in the
world between me and the events every
inch closer and it's even harder so at
some point I do think over here we've
been showing some of the tapes not all
you know you have to make a decision to
protect yourself and your well-being and
be able to report on it you know without
feeling the heaviness of it otherwise
you can't get through it you saw that
reporter the Israeli reporter today
trying to report you know as a
professional on the babies you know a
phrase I don't I don't know if any it's
ever been uttered before in the in news
coverage anywhere decapitated babies I I
don't know if anybody had ever even
considered that horror and then you find
40 like how do you go on with your life
how do you do anything other than take
up arms against these people and so I
fully understand what I am seeing online
with people saying Gaza must be raised
that's it there should be no more Gaza
it should look like a parking lot when
Israel is done with it that is how I
feel too and the only thing that would
dissuade me from that feeling is if it's
going to lead to more Destruction for
Israel and her allies you know if it's
going to provoke Iran or Hezbollah even
more and cause more headaches for Israel
because that to me seems like the only
quote proportionate response to what's
being done yeah proportionate I've
really come to hate that word it's a
disproportionate response it's oh so you
murdered and raped and burned and
beheaded our children and our women and
everything else let's say a thousand
could we get a thousand of your people
so we can proportionately do those same
things I mean how much of this now that
you're on this side on the media side
where you fully I I know that everything
well even when you were on Fox I know
you personally so I know everything was
coming out of you Megan Kelly yourself
and you were saying what you believed
but now in the total freedom to do this
the way you want and have those
conversations with your guys about how
how much of this can we show and how
much can I deal with and everything else
um how different is that than maybe when
you were in the corporate side of
things I mean I will say that when I was
at Fox they were very pro-israel and
they were never hesitant to show what
was being done to Israel by its enemies
Hamas included so I never felt
constrained there and certainly when
Isis was enacting its its
atrocities we didn't show everything
it's just again it's just too much and
and there are rules on cable um but we
showed a lot and we we didn't go easy on
them at NBC I was lucky enough not to
have this kind of thing pop up in my
very limited time there nor would they
be have been expecting the 9:00 a.m.
show to do it so I wasn't forced into
this kind of decision making um so I
think that's fortunate for me I'm seeing
it more right now with the mainstream
media and the choices they're Mak the
the editorial choices they're making
yeah they're going and have gone exactly
the same way that we saw them go during
BLM during these other you know massive
conflicts that have divided us and this
just just shouldn't be one this just
this just shouldn't be one this should
just be like there's a reason Joe Biden
sounds for the most part like you and me
right now it was very few things it was
shocking it was right before we're
taping this yeah yeah where we would all
sound the same now we can talk about his
remarks and I don't think he went far
enough but he his core message was a
good one and I agreed with what he was
saying where what's happening where you
and Mark lvin and I and the guy who runs
uh you know the ADL the green black guy
all agree but the the Washington Post
and Forbes and all the college campus
groups are saying something very
different it's like the media and the
academy that's been co-opted by the
wokest of the woke and as we've known
for some time that doesn't include Jews
it doesn't include Jewish people as
Barry Weiss once put it to me we don't
rate we don't count we're not on the
list of protected classes even though we
are technically a protected class right
well you can't have a minority that
succeeds it breaks the entire
intersectional calculator they they like
their minorities on their knees
basically forever I mean that that's
kind of how it works
um coming from I just want to hit the
mainstream media thing one more time
because I think we're I actually think
that this moment is like to me it's it's
actually causing a massive shift almost
the final shift in what we needed where
the mainstream media will not be
relevant anymore and the online will be
but I'm also a little concerned because
you know there's an awful lot of people
who talk for a living that have no idea
what they're talking about and know
nothing about history and have huge
audiences and confuse people either
intentionally or not what do you think
we do about that like we can do the we
can bash mainstream media all day long
and this or that but what do we do about
this other thing where it's like you're
pretty damn good and you're want on the
short list of people I trust and I guess
a couple people like me but like we're
not perfect and now people are going to
any anybody that has a webcam which is
basically everybody well and on you know
X formerly known as Twitter it's a
similar problem in that now that it's
been monetized and you get more money if
you've signed up for that which I
haven't um you get more money if you get
more engagement so it's in your interest
to just be as provocative as possible
and you lie in your pockets that way so
that's problematic I mean I'm I'm a
capitalist I'm not against people making
money but I the system is set up in a
fraught way and you could argue the same
is true RIT large you know cable news
does better if it bleeds it leads that
kind of thing um and so you have to find
ideally somebody who I mean you've done
very well I've done very well I I don't
need this paycheck in order to survive I
I need my Integrity to look at myself in
the mirror every morning so you have to
find a person like that doesn't have to
be me or you but you have to figure out
whether this person's there for dollars
or whether they're an honest broker and
whether they tell you the things you
don't want to hear even when it hurts
what you know is the anchor or the
host's side right that's how I would
make my decision but on something this
complex you really do need to be choosy
about where you get your info I mean
most of these anchors on CNN or MSNBC
forget that are you know a bunch of
twits who have absolutely no education
on any of this stuff and are too lazy to
do their homework they they want to be
Stars Dave they don't want to actually
be your guide through something as
complex as the Israeli Palestinian
relationship they don't want to do a
deep dive on Hamas and Gaza and what
happened in 2005 and what happened you
know what who started bombing who first
and why and why the blockade was put
into play they don't care they want what
gets them clicks and what gets you
clicks amongst the young people today is
to say that Israel is a
colonialized and that they're the
oppressor and that you're on the side of
the oppressed because that's what's hip
today you're a BLM and they're oppressed
and you're on the side of the lgbtq
people because they're the oppressors
they're not aggressors and therefore
you're on the side of the Palestinians
SL Hamas the poor Hamas oppressed people
who live in the new term quote an open
air prison gays for Palestine is very
different than Palestine for gays that's
what I always tell everybody it's like
it's like come on come on just just a
simple Google search would help you out
so much before you these idiotic posts
young people if you're looking for more
uncensored opinions from today's thought
leaders check out our media playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell